es ist unglaublich
zum ersten mal haben es youtuber und
namentlich bei city film von bully
geschafft so richtig hoch in die charts
einzusteigen in den top 100 war schon
mal mit ständer sein
ja richtig das war genau dies war platz
48 48 okay dieses mal aber
offensichtlich höher weil als sauger
elektro mit ihrem sauger eine community
habt und die hat es geschafft euch in
die top ten auf 1
denn er ist echt gigantisch also nachdem
ihr den song rausgehauen haben glaube
ich erst mal ging es dann immer höher
und wir haben schon immer gedacht das
ist jetzt das oberste und war geil geil
geil geil und dann letztendlich glaube
ich in der nacht sogar am ersten tag
kurz 40 platz zwei okay obwohl ganz
viele neue sachen auch raus gehauen
wurde war richtig gut das ist ein gefühl
als wenn er nach geschlafen oder sagt er
die ganze zeit mit wir waren wirklich in
immobilo ich muss immer gewinnen willst
aber geschlafen aber trotzdem weil wir
haben für den song der zweite drehtag
waren acht stunden eingeplant und sind
30 stunden draus geworden
wir haben die ganze nacht durch gedreht
bis 5 uhr morgens dann haben wir noch
das equipment wieder weggeräumt und dann
mit zwei tage am stück halt machen
komplett ausgebaut
nur noch umgesetzt sind und aber wir
haben es irgendwie hingekriegt und es
ist ein geiler song geworden und die
leute feiern
deswegen ist auch wieder wir sind
glücklich letzter song standard time der
ist ja nicht so richtig im radio
gespielt werden wie es jetzt mit dem
letzten sommer was ich auch gar nicht
verstehen hab ich verstehe es auch
überhaupt das war so ein
es war halt ein böses wort drin und
leidenschaft zerstört rausgerissen und
deswegen wurde es nicht im radio
gespielt haben wir extra probiert bei
der letzte sommer solche wörter zu
verhindern
und trotzdem bisher also eher wirtschaft
im radio gespielt und auch das haben wir
wieder unsere community zu verdanken hat
viele
angeschrieben und ja ich denke da kommt
jetzt auch noch mehr denke aber trotzdem
dass die radiosender einfach noch so ein
bisschen trotzdem noch so das gefühl
haben das ist youtube das weiß ich jetzt
nicht so recht wo kann ich das einordnen
ist das jetzt money boy oder ist das ist
das cool ist das noch so dass viele
einfach nicht verstehen warum ihr erfolg
habt warum das passiert warum der dieser
song plötzlichen den charts ist okay
dafür bin ich da weiß ich nicht also
bestimmt keiner altersgruppe wenn man
nicht auf youtube da ich gerade so
verrückt ist viel größer fragt man sich
das ja gut dann sind wir mal gespannt wo
es jetzt wirklich endgültig im charts
landet aber es wird höher als 48
einsteigen so viel gesichert das ist
schon ziemlich sich niemand gerne vorbei
weil das war wirklich so unser ziel was
wir von vornherein hatten wenn man das
schaffen sind wir überglücklich und ich
glaube ich dass wir auf einem super weg
sind überglücklich zu wenden wer hat das
sowieso okay gut dann viel spaß dabei
und wir sind gespannt auf den nächsten
sommer kommt ja bald wird dann auch bald
jetzt dann gleich sofort ja okay gut
also jetzt gleich jetzt dranbleiben und
dann kommt der song wollt ihr noch einen
song schreibt in die kommentare
haltern am flughafen schreibt in die
kommentare schreiben